the conspiracy theory is and and
you know keep in mind this is probably
dumb
okay right but take it take it for what
it is right all right
just conspiracy theories are fun
conspiracy theories are fun when you
just
believe them a little bit yeah don't let
it destroy your life
don't just be [ __ ] queuing on or
whatever yeah but just you know this one
you can just be like oh well what if
that's crazy
yeah and also a little scary yeah just
fool around a conspiracy theory
did the world end in 2012 oh
oh i like this okay existential crisis
time
so did the world actually end in 2012
well it was the year scientists at cern
finally found the higgs boson
you know the particle stephen hawking
predicted could destroy the universe
or in his own words caused the universe
to undergo a catastrophic vacuum decay
well what would happen if we destroyed
the universe would we know
maybe cern accidentally created a black
hole that sucked us in without us even
noticing
and we've actually just been living in
it some physicists some physicists
actually
actually believe this is possible
there's the old cliche argument that
nothing has felt right since 2012. i
agree with this maybe
maybe it has something to do with
growing up and getting older but ever
since
then it seems like the world descends
more and more into chaos each day
time even feels faster
there's some sort of calamity happening
almost daily um
did we all die and go to hell i don't
really believe that but some people do
maybe we're in
a similar situation to the characters in
the good place
okay hold on uh perhaps this universe
was destroyed by cern and our collective
consciousness was moved into a parallel
universe next door
it would be almost identical and then he
goes on to say
to talk about the mandela effect okay
which is like remembering something
different than it actually is okay like
a lot of people think that there was
a t in skechers there's not okay um
or or that nelson mandela died in the
80s but he
lived until 2013 blah blah okay people
swear to god that
the uh that the statue of liberty
is on ellis island what the [ __ ]
hold on sorry that should not have
happened i apologize
um people swear the statue of liberty is
on ellis island but it's actually on
liberty island
it's never been on ellis island but
there's there's a compilation on youtube
of people posing in front of ellis
island that is tagged
i'm at the statue of liberty and there's
nothing behind them
what [ __ ] weird is [ __ ] dude
obviously i didn't look that much into
it but i watched the compilation and
it's like
really eerie what hold on so the
argument is that like that
little things run that back what you
said there are people
posting videos okay here
mandela effects get much creepier though
some people remember the statue of
liberty being in a totally different
location that location being ellis
island it's actually on liberty
liberty island here's a painting clearly
depicting the statue at ellis island
with no other islands nearby was the
artist just not paying attention
did he just like it better this way i
don't really think so now if that's not
strange enough if you go in google maps
street view there's a few specific areas
of liberty island where the statue of
liberty is just gone
residue from the previous timeline
that's that one's kind of whack because
it comes just google maps there's so
many [ __ ] arrows yeah yeah
this account uploading these strange
pictures goes by the username of august
bartholdi
that's the designer of the lady liberty
herself the account also supports his
picture from the 1800s
he's google approved and he's posting
he posts pictures with no
statue of liberty okay
i'm not that one i'm not sold on well i
mean the mandela effect stuff
i don't really think it's that that's
not crazy
it's that um like convincing because
it's just us remembering [ __ ]
differently
yeah yeah that happens to us all the
[ __ ] time yeah
um well anyway a while back there was a
viral threat on 4chan posted by someone
who claimed to be one of the 23
scientists at cern responsible for
creating the mandel effect they claimed
the planet was destroyed and we were we
were placed in a simulated world
i mean this threat is really long so
this is the guy nick hinton is the guy
that camp
that wrote about this on twitter so
basically so go look them up if you want
to read the whole thread i know i didn't
do the best job but
and again like i probably sounded like
an idiot there yeah but it actually is
if you if you go oh maybe
and read through it it's really
interesting i'm trying to think of
major events that like got weird i mean
i definitely feel we're in some strange
entropy
state yeah we are i feel like we all
feel like that
yeah and also doesn't it seem like
time's going a little bit faster
that's cause we've been inside
yeah i mean it could also just be age
yeah like time's going faster because
we've just
yeah it's like we've been around longer
so we just less things are
new to us i was reading some [ __ ] about
the feasibility of like living forever
in this time
in this in our time like lifetime excuse
me
that [ __ ] bugged me out like basically
people were alleging that there's like a
significant possibility of developing
like the benjamin button [ __ ]
like we could just be like 80 and they'd
like take this damage
and just go backwards no way yeah what
happens
i don't know but i hope they could lock
me out at 22.
but yeah like when you get too young do
you take one that makes you older again
and then you just go back like you just
keep
i don't know i mean that that part they
you know wasn't figured out it's just
the possibility of reverse aging sales
which is crazy that's sick yeah
what if it like would man what would
that even be like
i know you got to think like there's got
to be there's got to be people that
like being 80 just like having
everything done for them yeah i'm not
going back yeah that's rules
yeah pudding every day i get to play
checkers with my boys
all [ __ ] day i'm chilling i don't
want to go back to work
that's what they're gonna do they're
gonna figure it out just so they can put
people back in the workforce
yeah super duper capitalism you guys
thought late stage capitalism was bad
wait till they figure out reverse aging
capitalism they're going to reverse age
everybody and put them in a best buy
gulag it's going to be crazy
we're going to be making microchips and
you know whatever the [ __ ]
where's this chip man there's all this
hype about vaccine and chip and this and
that and
nothing [ __ ] elon yeah i want mine dude
i know
i signed up for the list
[Laughter]
i just don't list for the cyber truck
i'm on the list for the chip
[Laughter]
give me that [ __ ] he's trying to be
testled out teed up oh yeah dude
teed up my lease for my car ends next
month
i don't know what the [ __ ] to do should
i should i lease a tesla
um honestly i thought about it coming
back from the
in the desert yes the instant torque and
that's the thing about oh we got major
flack by the way
for what we're just talking [ __ ] about
l.a no i mean
i i don't know i i don't want to talk
about that it's [ __ ]
what nah i was just laughing why because
uh
a dude dm me with a picture it was
looked like
a bunch of like young gang bangers it's
like why you putting l.a on blast homie
i was like
you listen to our podcast that's crazy
wait who i don't know it's just like an
instagram account i was like private
and he was like why are you putting l.a
on blast homie
you